Ben's in Colorado Merry Christmas Ben
how can I help
Merry Christmas Dave thanks for taking
my call
sure what's up so I have just a little
bit of student loan debt and then I'll
have the debt from the house and that'll
be it and so my question was after I get
rid of the student loan debt I'm kind of
nervous about just shoveling big piles
of money on my mortgage and being
miserable for the next you know nine
years until I'm 35 was not planning on
you being miserable the the ghazal
intensity stops after your debt free
except your home and have your emergency
fund in place you do need to run like
your hair is on fire until you get those
done okay because you're really you're
really living at the edge of a major
financial catastrophe if you don't have
an emergency fund and you still have a
pile of debt but when the student loans
are gone and you got your emergency fund
in place that's what we call baby steps
1 2 & 3 have you heard me talk about
that yeah so I've been watching you for
about a week and I have 18,000 dollars
in an emergency fund and I have 30 grand
worth of student debt that I can get
paid off in the next year ok well what
we teach is baby step ones a thousand
dollars and any money that you have
above that should go towards your debts
except your home baby step two is you
list your debts smallest to largest
sounds like you've got seventeen
thousand that you would throw at the 30
if you're following our plan and then
you would be debt-free very quickly how
much do you imma make a year what's your
household income
I make eighty one thousand okay and
making eighty one thousand we're paying
off the remaining thirteen thousand
should be Oh matter six months max
probably four months and then you
rebuild your emergency fund to three to
six months of expenses that's baby step
three now once you've done that then you
let your foot off the gas so by this
time next year you should be letting
your foot off the gas and have a fully
funded emergency fund with no payments
but a house payment now by letting the
foot off the gas I don't mean you start
spending like you're in Congress again I
mean you live intentionally you have a
written plan but you're doing things on
purpose and baby steps four or five and
six
are 15% of your income goes to
retirement this is the stage where if
you need to upgrade your car I want to
go on vacation upgrade your couch
whatever it is you save up pay cash for
that in addition the 15% going into
investments if you have kids baby step 5
is saving for their college and six is
paying off the house now people working
that plan in other words when you get to
baby step four you're in more of a
rhythm you're in less of a sprint is
that logical to you yeah okay okay once
you're there people working that plan or
paying off their home for the last 30
years I've been doing this in somewhere
around seven years and the the largest
study of millionaires ever done in North
America we did we completed it about a
year ago year and a half ago Chris Hogan
put it in a book called everyday
millionaires and one of the key data
points that we found as we're studying
the millionaire's is the typical
millionaire pays off their home in ten
point two years and so it becomes an
essential part of your overall net worth
and you have no payments anywhere Wow
now you're in a position to really start
building some wealth and be outrageously
generous and so that's where we coined
the phrase live like no one else so
later you can live and give like no one
else